Quartier général de la Légion étrangère.
Ce régiment est aussi le centre de recrutement
et de sélection des futurs légionnaires.
On peut s'y présenter
à n'importe quelle heure du jour et de la nuit.
Tous les matins, ils sont une vingtaine environ.
Ils ont entre 18 et 40 ans et viennent du monde entier.
Beaucoup ont voyagé pendant des mois.
Leur vie tient dans un sac à dos,
un sac en plastique
ou comme celui-ci, dans ses poches.
Aventuriers, déçus de la vie, clandestins,
tous sont là pour changer de vie.
Mais seulement un sur huit sera sélectionné.
- Déshabillez-vous, tout le monde !
Les tests vont durer deux semaines.
- Enlevez tout, les chaussettes, slip, tout !
1, 2, 3.
À partir de maintenant,
les candidats ne portent que des vêtements réglementaires,
tous identiques et surtout propres.
- 1, 2, 3.
- C'est important de se mettre dans la même tenue,le premier jour ?
- C'est comme ça.
Nous, on est tous passés par le même chemin.
C'est l'uniformité et comme ça,
ils apprennent tout de suite dès le début,
comment c'est dans l'armée.
- Même ceux qui ne vont pas rester ?
- Même ceux qu'on ne prend pas.
À l'appel de votre nom,
maintenant c'est : Présent Caporal Chef.
Changement d'apparence, mais aussi de nom.
À son arrivée, chacun a reçu une nouvelle identité.
Ceux qui sont pris devront garder ce nom au moins deux ans.
Une façon radicale de rompre avec le passé.
Inconvénient avec ce nouveau nom,
impossible de voyager hors de France,
de signer le moindre contrat ou de faire un emprunt.
- Ok maintenant vous allez manger,
le Caporal va vous amener à l'ordinaire ! À droite, droite !
Bon appétit !
- Merci.
L'ordinaire, c'est la cantine des légionnaires.
Premier contact avec le monde militaire
et la cuisine française,pour la plupart d'entre eux.
Le major Mestnik a 25 ans de service.
Son premier repas de soldat, c'était ici même.
Il y a longtemps.
- Ça vous rappelle quelque chose ?
- C'est sûr que ça me rappelle quelque chose,
même si ça remonte assez loin dans le temps,
parce que c'est vraiment le moment où on se demande
qu'est-ce qui va nous arriver ?
Est-ce qu'on a fait le bon choix ?
Est-ce qu'on a frappé à la bonne porte ? Etc.
Ils s'aperçoivent que quelles que soient les choses
qu'on va leur demander,
même qu'on va faire des efforts physiques importants.
Ils auront toujours un toit
et ils auront toujours à un repas,
quoi qu'ils arrivent.
Dans leur tête, c'est important.
- Ça, c'est normal !
- C'est normal, pour un Français peut-être.
Mais pour des gens qui sont venus à la nage ou en marchant
de l'autre bout de la planète.
C'est quand même un repère important,
de savoir qu'ils auront une assiette
avec un repas tous les jours.
Cet homme qui s'assoit a connu la faim et la prison.
Venu à pied d'Éthiopie,
il a mis trois ans à rejoindre Aubagne.
Il ne le sait pas encore, mais la Légion le gardera.
- Si vous ne touchez pas la ligne,
je vous fais un chèque.
Les critères de sélection sont ceux de l'armée française,
ni plus ni moins.
- On travaille avec la souris.
Les candidats peuvent être éliminés à chaque instant.
Ici, on ne cherche pas des surhommes,
mais des hommes motivés et fiables.
Aussi leur demande-t-on de ne rien cacher de leur passé.
- Est-ce que tu as eu des soucis avec la justice ?
- Oui, j'ai été arrêté pour attaque à main armée.
- Tu as fait de la prison ?
- Non, de la préventive 6 mois.
Cet homme ne sera pas retenu
mais donnera chacun une deuxième chance.
C'est un principe sacré à la Légion étrangère.
- Je suis venu d'abord visiter Paris
et je me suis présenté à la légion.
- Après avoir vu Paris ?
- Oui !
- Comment ça ?
- Je pensais que ce serait bien de voir la Tour Eiffel
et l'Arc de Triomphe,
d'avoir une idée de ce qu'est la France.
Je veux être différent, faire quelque chose de ma vie.
- Qu'y a-t-il de si spécial dans la légion ?
- Par rapport aux autres armées dans le monde,
on dit que c'est la meilleure.
Meilleure qu'en Amérique, au Canada ou en Grande-Bretagne.
La seconde chance, ça ne veut pas dire tout pardonner.
Les auteurs de crimes de sang ou de viol, par exemple,
sont systématiquement écartés.
- On est parfois un peu prisonniers de notre image
et on a des candidats à l'engagement
qui pensent qu'il faut qu'ils avouent.
Je dirais beaucoup de délits
pour avoir une chance d'être pris,
puisque pour eux, si on n'a pas fait un délit,
on n'a pas de raison réelle de venir à la Légion étrangère.
Et donc ils vont avoir tendance à en avouer un ou deux.
Ce qui est très clair, c'est qu'on ne veut pas de criminels
aujourd'hui au sein de la Légion étrangère.
Et je dirais que c'est une règle de base
qui a toujours prévalu.
On a toujours été attentif à ce point-là
et je dirais encore plus aujourd'hui
pour des raisons assez simples.
C'est que d'une part,
la justice internationale est de plus en plus présente
et donc on ne veut pas confier les armes de la France
à des gens qu'on ne connaîtrait pas bien
ou qui auraient déjà commis des crimes
et qui seraient des criminels.
Impossible de se fier à la seule parole des candidats.
Derrière cette porte, une vingtaine de spécialistes
du renseignement enquêtent avec l'aide
des ambassades et d'Interpol.
- Venez avec moi, tout le monde.
Parmi ces hommes, beaucoup rêvent de rejoindre l'élite,
les légionnaires parachutistes.
- Je veux aller au REP !
- Au REP, à Calvi ?
- À Calvi, oui !
Je suis venu exprès en France pour ça !
Je suis de la Guinée.
Mon grand-père a fait la Première Guerre mondiale,
la guerre d'Indochine.
C'est ça mon seul rêve, de faire la Légion étrangère.
- Et si ça ne marche pas ?
- J'espère que ça va marcher, à mon avis.
- Si je dis " Toilettes pisser".
Vous prenez les bols qui sont là, vous pissez dedans.
Vous me ramenez l'urine là-bas, je vais faire le test.
Après vous les videz dans les chiottes, vous les lavez
et vous les posez comme ils sont maintenant ! Ok ?
- Oui Commandant !
Les examens médicaux sont aussi le moyen d'en savoir un peu plus
sur les candidats, leur état de santé et leurs habitudes.
Et là aussi, mieux vaut jouer la franchise.
- Cocaïne toi ?
- Non.
- Non ?
- Marihuana ?
- Non.
- Ecstasy ?
Non, ok !
- Les gens qui consomment des drogues, c'est rédhibitoire ?
Ils sont éliminés ?
- Il faut demander au médecin.
Je ne sais pas, c'est mal vu en tout cas.
- Première fois ici ?
T'es quoi, chinois ?
- Oui.
- Voilà, c'est marqué ici.
Est-ce qu'il est ici pour la première fois ?
- Vous savez combien de langues ?
- 2, 4, 6, 8.
10, 12, 13 langues !
Ce candidat vient de Belgique, il porte des lunettes.
Il sait que c'est son point faible.
- Je ne la vois pas.
Si je suis recalé, j'en reviendrais !
On a trois chances. Je les tenterai toutes les trois.
Si par exemple, c'est pour mes yeux, j'irai me faire soigner
et je reviendrai.
- Vous avez dit autour de vous que vous partez à la Légion ?
- Oui.
- Et ?
- Tout le monde n'est pas d'accord.
- Vous voulez aller où après ?
Je veux dire si vous êtes pris ?
- J'aimerais bien être dans les parachutistes !
- Le REP ?
- Oui.
- Pourquoi le REP ?
- C'est un rêve, sauter en parachute.
C'est l'aventure.
- Vous pouvez le faire dans le civil, sauter en parachute.
- Ouais, mais en même temps, la Légion,
c'est un mode de vie, le respect, la camaraderie.
Des choses qu'on trouve dans la Légion,
qu'on ne trouve pas dans la société.
- C'est pas un mythe, un peu ?
- Peut-être !
Ouais, je verrais bien.
Mais pour moi, non. Je l'ai vraiment à cœur.
C'est vraiment ce que je veux.
- Serge !
Déshabille-toi !
Est-ce que tu as des problèmes avec la police, des dettes,
des enfants que tu ne veux pas reconnaître ?
- Non, non, non, pas du tout.
- L'entente avec tes parents est bonne ?
Pas de violence dans un foyer ?
Les entretiens sont nombreux.
Ils portent sur le passé judiciaire,
mais aussi sur des aspects plus intimes comme la famille
ou la vie sentimentale.
Des informations décisives afin de connaître la psychologie
et la motivation des candidats.
- Pour le REP, attention, c'est pas facile.
C'est pas l'armée, c'est la Légion !
Il y a plus de droits de l'homme,
c'est le devoir de l'homme.
Face aux candidats chinois, ce sera un peu plus compliqué.
L'infirmier tente quelques mots de mandarin,
sans succès.
Le candidat n'a aucun papier, il prétend être chinois.
Alors l'infirmier l'invite à désigner
son pays dans un atlas.
- Philippines ?
- Chine.
- T'imagines ce qu'il se passe dans sa tête ?
- Affirmatif.
Il est venu de loin.
Il a attendu longtemps.
Il risque de se faire virer.
Il n'a pas de papiers, ils sont sans visa.
Ce sont des jeunes qui viennent un peu "desperados".
Comme on dit chez nous.
Il faut, à chacun, leur donner une chance.
D'autant plus qu'ils peuvent devenir de très bons soldats,
de très bon militaire.
- Toi, petit ?
un an, deux ans, trois ans, quatre ans ?
- Moi ?
- Oui. Quel âge ?
- 34 ans
- Il faut savoir qu'en Chine,
vous comptez dès la conception, l'âge.
Et en Occident en général, ça dépend de pays, mais en général,
en Occident, on compte à partir de la naissance.
Maman, accoucher, paf !
Toi, sortir, voilà donc toi 33.
En Chine, toi 34.
C'est ça !
Ce poisson dessiné signifie qu'il est pêcheur.
C'est du moins la conclusion de l'infirmière.
Mais qui est vraiment cet homme ?
Desperados, clandestins à la recherche de papiers français.
C'est ce que la Légion va chercher à savoir
durant toute la période de test.
Ceux-ci sont ici depuis deux semaines.
Pour eux, la sélection est terminée.
C'est l'heure de vérité.
- Engagé, volontaire, Abert !
- Présent, mon Lieutenant !
- Engagé volontaire, Ivasera.
- Engagé volontaire, Clermont.
- Présent, mon Lieutenant !
Ceux qui s'en vont.
Ils vont récupérer leurs affaires personnelles.
Et partiront aussitôt dans la vie civile.
Vous êtes pris !
Votre contrat !
Cinq ans.
Cinq ans, c'est long !
Est-ce qu'il y a parmi vous des candidats
qui veulent repartir à la vie civile, là, tout de suite
avec vos camarades qui s'en vont ?
- Non, mon Lieutenant !
- Donc, si vous voulez changer d'avis.
Vous pouvez les faire, tout de suite.
Toi, tu n'étais pas sûr de toi !
- Si, je suis sûr.
- Tu es sûr de toi.
Toi, t'es quelle nationalité ?
- Brésilien !
- C'est bon, là !
- C'est bon.
- Tu restes ?
- Oui.
- Tu es sûr ?
- Oui
- Tu parles français ?
- Non.
Tu apprendras !
Toi!
Tu restes ?
- Oui.
- Donc première chose, on va vous habiller.
Vous allez ressembler dorénavant
à de vrais légionnaires.
Pas tout à fait encore, mais ça va venir.
Ressembler à de vrais légionnaires.
Ça commence par la coupe réglementaire 2 mm.
Il y a bien sûr l'uniforme
et surtout ce papier blanc.
- Engagé volontaire.
Leur premier contrat valable cinq ans.
Mais il y a une période d'essai.
Pour le moment, ils sont engagés volontaires,
pas encore légionnaires.
- Maintenant, vous sortez un stylo.
Ils reçoivent leur paquetage.
Dans ces sacs, les seuls vêtements qu'ils porteront
au cours des mois à venir.
- À l'extérieur, c'est béret sur la tête.
Touche finale, le béret vert.
Et sur leur poitrine, leur nouveau nom.
Il faudra s'y habituer.
- Quand vous prenez, vous le sortez !
Vous le prenez par la visière.
Le képi blanc, c'est la marque des légionnaires.
Pour le moment, il reste bien emballé.
Ils ont juste le droit de l'essayer.
- Le béret vert, il peut le porter, il n'y a pas de souci.
Le képi, là, c'est autre chose.
Il faut le mériter.
Avant de devenir des légionnaires et de porter le képi blanc.
Ces hommes vont apprendre les bases du métier de soldat.
C'est ce qu'on appelle l'instruction.
Direction Castelnaudary, à 400 km de là.
Ceux-là sont en instruction depuis deux semaines.
Complètement isolés du monde extérieur,
ils vivent dans une ancienne ferme.
Ils sont 40, 23 nationalités.
Ils apprennent les rudiments de leur métier.
Marchez au pas et chanter, entre autres.
- Politi, sors des rangs !
C'est l'heure de réciter le code d'honneur de légionnaires.
- Envoyez !
- Légionnaire, tu es un volontaire
servant la France avec honneur et fidélité.
Chaque légionnaire est ton frère d'armes
quelle que soit sa nationalité, sa race, sa religion.
La mission est sacrée, tu l'exécutes jusqu'au bout
et si besoin, en opération, au péril de ta vie.
Au combat, tu n'abandonnes jamais.
ni tes morts, ni tes blessés, ni tes armes.
Dorénavant, ce code devra guider chacun de leurs actes.
Mais devenir légionnaire,
c'est avant tout se forger un corps solide.
- Aller, c'est le dernier, c'est parti,
C'est parti ! Allez !
Ces hommes n'ont pas été sélectionnés
pour leurs qualités sportives,
mais plutôt sur leur bonne santé générale.
Alors les différences de niveau physique sont énormes.
- Les Français, les francophones sont le plus faible,
alors que les Russes et les mecs des pays de l'Est
font beaucoup de sport à l'école, à partir de 10, 11 ans.
Les Français et les Anglais
sont plus faibles que les autres.
Pour le parcours du combattant et
tout au long de l'instruction.
La règle, c'est que les plus forts tirent
les plus faibles vers le haut.
C'est ce qu'on appelle la cohésion.
Un pour tous et tous pour un, en quelque sorte.
- Allez, ..., allez !
La pêche ?
- Oui, sergent.
- Vous êtes fatigués ?
- Non.
- Ok, alors en position.
Les pousser à bout physiquement,
c'est aussi le moyen de faire craquer les moins motivés
et de repérer les meilleurs,
ceux qui voudront devenir parachutiste par exemple.
- Y en a qui ne vont pas continuer ?
- Oui, oui !
Je suis sûr et certain.
- Il y en a qui seront très bons ?
- Oui, un très bon, même très bon.
Des bons sportifs, vraiment très bon.
Cet homme fait partie des très bons,
Politi, italien, il veut devenir parachutiste.
- Ici, il faut toujours écouter les ordres,
il faut être fort dans la tête.
Le mec qui laisse tomber les choses,
il n'est pas fait pour la légion.
Stand Chew est roumain.
Lui aussi rêve de sauts et d'aventures.
Sa force, c'est sa bonne humeur.
- Je suis venu ici pour faire l'armée,
pour la discipline, pour camaraderie.
Pour le 2ᵉ REP Parachutisme.
Et puis il y a Chicos, il est Hongrois.
- Il a une bonne chance d'aller en REP ?
- Oui, c'est certain,
il va y aller, c'est du 100% !
Pour le REP, il est bien.
Il est discipliné, bon en sport.
- Tireur n°2, tir terminé, sécurité vérifiée.
Chicos est aussi très appliqué.
C'est un peu la mascotte du groupe.
- Combien de fois l'a-t-on parcourue,
cette petite piste ?
et ascaris, aïdo,
aïe safari.
Après le parcours du combattant,
les soldats ont cinq minutes chrono
pour remettre un peu d'ordre dans leur tenue.
Cirer les Rangers surtout.
Car des Rangers mal cirées, c'est un motif de punition.
C'est l'heure du cours de français.
Avant de s'engager, la grande majorité
d'entre eux n'avaient aucune notion de notre langue.
C'est l'été, la leçon se déroule en plein air.
- La date aujourd'hui ?
- 13 juillet 2006.
- Ok, c'est bon. Assis-toi !
- SE !
ME !
TE !
Ok, regardez !
Que fais-tu ?
- Je me rase.
- Que fais-tu ?
- Que fait-il ?
- Il se rase.
La méthode est éprouvée.
Démonstration, répétition.
Alors, celui qui a gardé le béret vert, en l'occurrence,
c'est le francophone.
Voilà donc, moi, ça me permet de les identifier
et d'éviter de leur poser des questions.
J'interroge systématiquement ceux qui n'ont pas de béret.
Qui sont les non-francophones.
- Je me rase.
Stanchou, le Roumain a des facilités en langues.
- Est-ce que vous êtes noté sur ce que vous apportez ?
- Oui, je suis noté.
Moi, j'ai une note à la fin pour le trinôme.
J'ai volontaire Stanchou, qui Roumains,
qui parlent un peu français, allemand et portugais.
Je crois ?
- Non espagnole.
- Voilà.
Et puis ben mon binôme qui est russe.
Qui ne parle que russe.
On a une note globale en fait pour le trinôme.
- Ah d'accord !
Vous avez intérêt à être un bon professeur.
- Oui, mais tous les jours, on se répète.
Et puis, tous les jours, il apprend des mots.
Donc c'est bien.
- Des hommes, comme les doigts d'une main.
- Des camarades !
La méthode pédagogique est différente pour nous
que celle qui est enseignée dans l'armée française.
Vous pouvez parler des heures avec eux.
S'ils ne comprennent pas, ça ne sert à rien.
Donc démontrer, ...,
démontrer, expliquer, restituer.
Que fais-tu ?
- Je me lave les mains.
- Que fais-tu ?
- La langue française est un peu difficile.
- Tu comprends tout ce qui se passe ici,
ce que les chefs disent ?
- Euh, envions 60 %.
Politi a de la famille en
France, il a déjà de bonnes bases.
- Personne ne devient bon en 15 jours.
Il faut de la patience,
mais normalement en 16 semaines,
on a un bon niveau de base.
35 000 morts, 35 000 légionnaires morts pour la France.
Le cours de français, c'est aussi l'occasion
de faire un peu d'histoire.
- Ok, premier régiment étranger de cavalerie.
C'est où ?
- C'est à Aubagne.
- À Aubagne ?
Toi, tu passes derrière là-bas et tu fais 30 pompes.
Allez hop, demi-tour droite.
T'es francophone, toi, t'as aucune excuse.
Allez hop là.
- On continue.
La bonne réponse, c'était Orange et il faut que ça rentre.
- Les rappels historiques comme ça.
Pour les jeunes légionnaires, c'est important ?
- Je peux vous citer un exemple, hier j'avais un cours,
les grandes dates de la Légion.
J'ai parlé de 39-45, en l'occurrence.
Des Polonais ne savaient pas qu'il y avait eu la guerre
dans leur pays.
La guerre, certains l'ont déjà fait dans leur pays,
mais ils restent discrets sur ce sujet.
Pour la majorité, l'exercice de camouflage est une première
et il s'en donne à cœur joie.
- Voilà, tu ressembles à quelqu'un, quand même.
- Mon gant est très grand,
et je ne peux travailler avec.
Les futurs légionnaires vont apprendre à se déplacer
par groupes de trois en évitant les pièges d'un ennemi éventuel.
Un exercice qui exige de s'exprimer à haute voix en français.
- Chicos a sa méthode personnelle.
Il écrit tout ce qu'il entend dans ce carnet.
- Ça suit, ça suit !
- C'est de la phonétique hongroise :
Un carrefour, une piste à droite.
- Tout phonétique ?
- Tout phonétique, Oui.
- Tu vas faire le parcours avec ton carnet dans la main ?
- Ah non, il va faire le parcours vraiment !
Là, il révise vite fait, retient quelques phrases,
les points clés.
Engagé volontaire Chicos, en tête !
Dès que tu es prêt, en avant !
Chicos part en tête.
- Voilà, c'est parti.
Cinq mètres,
Ça, c'est trois mètres.
À chaque obstacle, il doit prévenir les autres
et expliquer ce qu'il voit.
Il veut bien faire, mais sans l'aide de son petit carnet,
il est stressé.
- Qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
- Direction la main, distance...
- Non, attends, direction mon bras.
- Direction mon bras.
- Il est où ton bras ? Montre-moi ton bras !
- Il est où ton bras.
- D'accord, c'est pas mal.
- Écoute !
- Oui, Sergent !
- Ton bras. Il est où ton bras ?
Calme-toi.
Voilà, c'est bon.
Il est où ton bras ?
- Direction mon bras !
- Il est là. OK.
Pour l'instant, l'instructeur préfère en rire.
Lui aussi est passé par là.
C'est bon, va pas trop loin.
- On a l'impression qu'ils vont jamais y arriver,
avec le Français, c'est pas possible.
- C'est bon, on commence toujours comme ça.
C'est bon, là.
- Ça commence toujours comme ça ?
-  Oh oui.
- Vous vous étiez comme ça ?
- Oh, où tu vas là !
Halte !
Attendez, s'il vous plaît.
Où tu vas ?
C'est difficile à croire, mais dans quelques mois,
ces hommes seront certainement des soldats d'élite.
- Il est là, il va te planter le couteau
dans la jambe tranquille.
- Est-ce que vous pouvez lui demander si, par moments,
il n'est pas un peu découragé avec la langue ?
Si ça ne lui fait pas peur ?
- Tu n'as pas de problème avec le français ?
- Non, non, pas de problème...
- De toute façon, on y arrive tous.
- Là, Chicos, je suis désolé, je ne parle pas hongrois.
Alors désolé.
Voilà, direction mon bras.
Appui mutuel, appui mutuel !
Voilà, on va vous tuer sur place.
Viens ici mon petit !
Oh Zoran, Qu'est-ce que t'as fait ?
Quelle connerie t'as fait ? Non.
Chicot apprendra le français.
En attendant, il mise sur ses qualités physiques.
Mais après 15 jours d'entraînement intensif,
même les plus costauds commencent à souffrir.
Politi est gêné par son corps très lourd.
- Je suis beaucoup fatigué, j'ai mal au genou...
- Et la tête ?un coca
La tête, ça va, il n'y a pas de problème.
- Fatigué pourquoi ?
- Pour les soirs et les nuits,
pour la fatigue accumulée depuis 15 jours
Ici, tu fatigues beaucoup, tu ne manges pas beaucoup.
Tu dors pas beaucoup, très stressé, c'est tout !
- 4, 5, ..., 10.
Debout ! Prends le sac !
- Pourquoi vous les faites en même temps les pompes ?
- C'est l'exemple !
Si je donne une petite punition parce qu'ils ont mal fait
et si je ne le fais pas avec eux,
après, ils n'ont pas de respect pour les caporaux.
Celui qui faisait des pompes il y a un instant se rebelle.
Il refuse de creuser son poste de combat
et ce n'est pas la première fois qu'il désobéit.
Manifestement, il ne veut plus continuer.
- Alors qu'est-ce qu'il se passe ?
- Il ne veut pas travailler.
- Pas du tout ?
C'est-à-dire ?
- Il voulait partir.
- Définitivement, il veut repartir civil,
ou il ne veut pas travailler ?
- Le jeune homme est goguenard.
Il sait qu'il a gagné.
L'adjudant-chef Leroy a été prévenu.
Il téléphone à son supérieur.
- Oui mon capitaine, moi, je n'en veux pas ici.
Je n'ai pas demandé à récupérer de la merde pareille.
Et là, je vous dis, il est dans un cas, là,
il est en train de faire chier tout le monde.
On peut le foutre en taule directement.
La PM, elle vient le chercher.
Ils le mettent en taule.
Là, il y a tout ce qu'il faut,
un refus d'obéissance, faut pas s'emmerder avec ça.
- Qu'est-ce que c'est le danger, dans un cas comme ça ?
- C'est qu'il contamine le reste de la section.
- Contaminée. Ça veut dire quoi ?
- Ça veut dire ?
Actuellement, c'est un mec qui veut partir.
Donc, arrête de rigoler tête de nœud.
Il va me faire du mauvais esprit.
Il va pas participer aux activités.
Donc rapidement, ça peut être la limitation.
Qu'est-ce qu'il ne lui plait pas dans la Légion ?
- Tout, y a rien qui lui plaît.
- Pourquoi t'es venu alors ?
- Il ne veut pas dire !
- T'as quel âge ?
- 28.
- À 28 ans, tu sais toujours pas
ce que tu veux faire de ta vie.
Bonne chance, alors.
Allez donc, tu gardes avec toi là-bas.
En attendant, l'appel de capitaine.
On va pas perdre de temps avec lui.
Il s'expliquera avec les big chefs.
Eux, ils ont des solutions plus radicales que moi.
Cet homme sera puni et son contrat dénoncé,
il ne pourra plus jamais revenir à la Légion étrangère.
- Le légionnaire, c'est quelqu'un d'instable.
À un moment, il faut trouver sa voie.
On ne peut pas rester comme ça à 28 ans,
mais on envoie fréquemment dans ce cas-là,
mais les gens en prennent sur eux.
École de volonté, franchissent le premier cap,
cette période d'instruction et la première année de contrat.
Puis après, c'est parti pour la plupart,
au moins jusqu'à cinq ans.
Donc lui, visiblement, il est fragile moralement.
Et puis, il n'a pas réussi à tenir.
- Est-ce qu'il y a des périodes où il n'y a plus
ce genre de problème que d'autres ?
- L'hiver !
L'hiver, je peux vous en parler. Ça, c'est clair.
- Pourquoi ?
- Le froid !
Pendant l'instruction, abandon et désertion sont fréquents.
Confort sommaire, manque de sommeil, discipline de fer
et nouvelle culture pour la plupart.
Les esprits fragiles vacillent.
Pour certains, la vie en groupe est un enfer.
Même dans les sanitaires, pas moyen de s'isoler un peu.
À la sortie de la douche, chaque soldat est inspecté.
Car l'hygiène aussi, cela s'apprend.
- Je ne veux pas voir des mecs
qui se présentent devant moi avec de la colle sur le pied !
Allez, tu repasses !
Pour certains, ce n'est pas obligatoire.
Il y a des nationalités où se laver tous les jours,
ça n'existe pas, c'est se laver occasionnellement.
D'ailleurs, en France, c'était comme ça
il y a quelques dizaines d'années, en arrière.
Nous dans chaque chambre, le chef d'équipe contrôle
si le gars s'est bien lavé, les oreilles, les dents, etc...
Il faut aussi éviter que certains
ne dissimulent leurs blessures.
- Qu'est-ce qui est vérifié là ?
- L'état des pieds parce que déjà on arrive
en troisième semaine d'instruction
et ils sont fragiles physiquement
et moralement actuellement.
Ils sont affaiblis.
Une blessure, ça peut dégénérer très rapidement.
On a marché avant-hier 25 km,
on remarche ce soir 25 km !
Le caporal qui est auxiliaire sanitaire,
regarde l'état des pieds, pour voir les dégâts.
C'est l'heure de la soupe, le déjeuner,
mais avant une dernière formalité.
- Section, garde-à-vous !
Le temps pour le boudin.
- Encore un giron d'e*****
sous la guitoune de l'aumônier.
Tiens, voilà du boudin...
C'est une version paillarde du boudin,
l'hymne de la Légion étrangère.
- Bon appétit.
- Merci Sergent.
Au menu, que du costaud.
Viande, frites et jambon pour tout le monde.
Ici, pas de place aux considérations religieuses.
Les soldats ont intérêt à prendre des forces,
car la journée est encore longue.
- Cette petite piste.
19 h, le long du canal du midi,
la section a été transportée à 25 km de la ferme.
Maintenant, il faut rentrer à pied,
20 kilos sur le dos, une arme en bandoulière,
des rangers neuves.
Ils vont souffrir.
- Tu sais sur quoi tu pars ?
- Non, c'est l'inconnu total.
Comme d'habitude.
Ils vont pas dormir ou très peu dormir cette nuit.
Puisque là il est 19 h et il nous reste 25 km à faire.
- Ce sont des gens qui, il y a un mois,
auraient été capables de faire ça ?
- Pour 75 %, je dirais non.
- C'est vraiment un d'aguerrissement ?
- Oui, c'est clair.
- Formation physique ?
- Une formation physique, morale, d'aguerrissement.
Là, il y en a qui commencent à subir là.
- À quoi vous le voyez ?
- À la mine abattue,
la tête entre les épaules, tête baissée.
- Quand on marche, on n'est pas ici dans la tête.
- T'es où dans ta tête ?.
- Je pense.
- Tu penses à quoi ?
- Qu'est-ce que je vais faire après
ou qu'est-ce que je fais aujourd'hui
et qu'est-ce que je faisais avant.
Des choses comme ça.
Je ne pense pas à mes jambes.
- À quoi tu penses ?
- A ma fiancée, elle m'attend !
- Et ça t'aide ?
- Oh oui, bien sûr !
Dans une semaine, ils devront marcher 60 km.
Ceux qui finiront, deviendront des légionnaires.
14 juillet, 5 h du matin.
Nous sommes au fort de Nogent, en banlieue parisienne.
Dans quelques heures, les légionnaires du deuxième régiment
étranger de génie vont défiler sur les Champs-Elysées.
Derniers préparatifs dans la chambre des sapeurs.
Pour le défilé, ils vont incarner les pionniers
qui ouvraient la voie aux armées à la hache.
- Vous la gardez toute l'année la barbe ?
- Non, on commence depuis le mois du janvier,
parce qu'on a défilé pour le Cameroun aussi.
Pour la fête de la Légion.
Le tablier, c'est une tradition.
Les anciens, ils, portaient le tablier pour se protéger
des obstacles, des os, des morceaux de bois.
C'est mes médailles.
C'est les missions que j'ai faites !
J'ai fait Afghanistan,
je fais au Kosovo,
Guyane, Djibouti.
- Et aujourd'hui Paris ?
- Aujourd'hui, c'est les Champs Élysée.
Les 300 légionnaires qui vont défiler,
viennent du plateau d'Albion, dans le sud de la France.
Le major Colin est le chef des pionniers.
- Enlève ta main au fond là-bas.
Aucun détail ne lui échappe.
- Elle n'est pas fermée sa poche, là.
Avec le chef de l'État,
ce sera lui le plus filmé de tout le défilé.
Il le sait.
- Balancez les bras !
Alors, il est un peu nerveux.
2 h plus tard sur les Champs-Elysées.
Pour la plupart de ces hommes,
ce 14 juillet est une première.
C'est aussi l'occasion de découvrir la capitale.
- Ça fait combien de temps que vous portez cette barbe ?
- Ça fera un an, le 30 juillet 2006.
- C'est confortable ?
- C'est un enfer.
Il ne faut pas croire, parce qu'on garde la barbe,
qu'on gagne cinq minutes le matin.
Vous ne gagnez pas cinq minutes,
vous perdez un quart d'heure.
- Il y a quelqu'un qui vous regarde,
auquel vous allez penser en particulier ?
- Oui, ma mère.
- Elle va vous reconnaître votre mère ?
- Non, parce que les gens
ont beaucoup de mal à me reconnaître.
Ce que je réalise aujourd'hui,
c'est un rêve de jeune légionnaire.
Ce légionnaire, lui aussi, réalise un rêve.
Il vient d'un pays en guerre, l'Irak.
- Quand je suis entré au régiment,
on m'a dit que je défilerais le 14 juillet.
C'était quelque chose de magnifique.
Je le souhaitais et on est là aujourd'hui !
- Vous l'avez dit à tout le monde ?
- Oui, je l'ai dit à tout le monde de regarder la télé.
Le lieutenant colonel Boucher
est le chef de corps de ce régiment.
C'est son deuxième défilé à Paris.
La dernière fois, j'étais en grand uniforme de Saint-Cyrien
et c'était il y a 23 ans.
J'avais une haute émotion de jeunes officiers à l'époque,
de jeunes Saint-Cyrien.
Donc non, je n'imaginais pas que, plus de 20 ans après,
je re-défilerai à la tête d'un régiment de Légion.
Ça n'arrive qu'une fois dans une vie.
Le plus chanceux de l'armée de terre.
Donc si l'émotion est une pression,
oui, on a une certaine pression aujourd'hui.
- Portez arme !
Au passage du chef de l'État,
le légionnaire irakien réalise tout le chemin
parcouru depuis Bagdad.
Il est militaire, mais il vit dans un pays en paix.
Il a un avenir.
Cela fait 4 h que les légionnaires battent le pavé.
De toutes les troupes à pied,
ce sont ceux qui partent en dernier.
- On passe en dernier, car les pas sont différents.
On n'a pas le même pas que l'armée de terre
ou les autres armées.
Leur pas est plus lent.
Ils sont un peu mystérieux
et ils ont une fanfare.
Le public adore.
À l'applaudimètre, il remporte la palme, comme d'habitude.
Un peu plus tard dans le quartier de l'Opéra.
Le légionnaire irakien se remet de ses émotions
en bonne compagnie.
Visiblement, le képi blanc, ça marche.
- On est toujours content, regarder les filles !
Quand on est rentré dans le défilé,
il y a eu beaucoup d'applaudissement.
C'était pas mal
et j'espère qu'on a fait quelque chose de bien.
Mon père a fait l'armée,
à part lui, personne d'autre dans la famille.
- Il s'est battu contre l'Iran à l'époque votre père ?
- Ouais. Il s'est battu contre l'Iran,
il a fait la 1ere guerre du Golfe.
- Et quand vous lui avez dit que vous seriez
un militaire légionnaire, ça ne lui a pas fait peur ?
- Non, il a dit : fait attention à toi.
Tu es assez grand, fais ta vie.
Au même moment, devant la mairie du 17ᵉ arrondissement.
Dans toute la capitale,
les Parisiens viennent à la rencontre de leurs soldats.
Derrière cette vitre,
le sergent-chef Vlakavic, se concentre.
Il est  tchèque. Il n'a pas défilé ce matin.
Son heure de gloire, c'est maintenant.
Il va devenir Français.
- Vous êtes nerveux ?
- Un petit peu.
- Qui va vous donner le document ?
- Même pour moi, c'est un peu la surprise.
Je ne crois pas que ce sera le Chef de Corps.
Je pense que ça sera le maire.
Vlakavic tente de contenir son émotion.
Cette nationalité française, c'est un vrai choix de vie.
Il servait la France.
Désormais, il va servir son pays.
- Sergent Vlakavic, 12 ans et 3 mois de service.
À vos ordres, mon colonel.
En acquérant la nationalité Française,
vous êtes devenu citoyen de notre pays.
Recevez, Monsieur, l'expression de mon plus amical salut.
Bien cordialement.
Jacques Chirac, Président de la République.
Après trois ans de service, chaque légionnaire
est en droit de demander la nationalité française,
mais tous ne le font pas.
- Allez à ta santé.
- Messieurs, nous levons le verre à la promotion.
Pour Vlakavic, c'est un jour inoubliable
qui se fête à la française, au champagne.
- C'est demain que je vais réaliser.
Je perds la nationalité tchèque,
mais je la garderai toujours dans mon coeur.
C'est dommage que chez nous,
la loi interdit la double nationalité.
Mais c'est la France qui me paye, c'est la France qui me plaît
parce que c'est le plus joli pays d'Europe !
Maintenant, les enfants, ma femme...
...On va être dans la légalité en France.
Ma femme n'avait ps de carte de séjour.
C'est un très grand moment pour moi.
Retour à Castelnaudary.
Chez les engagés volontaires, les sourires sont revenus.
C'est enfin le départ pour la marche képi blanc,
celle qui va leur permettre de devenir de vrai légionnaire.
Politi, l'italien est confiant.
Stanchou encourage les copains.
Quant à Chicos, il attend ce jour depuis des années.
Il ne le sait pas encore,
mais il va vivre l'enfer.
- Départ pour la marche képi blanc.
Deux jours de marche, 50 à 60 km,
à l'issue la remise képi blanc.
Et puis l'entrée, pour eux, dans le monde légionnaire.
On le voit différemment, mais pour eux,
c'est un moment très important.
Les futurs légionnaires, la relève.
- Tu as déjà marché 60 km comme ça ?
- Dans ma vie ?
Non jamais !
C'était tranquille ma vie civile, pas comme ça !
2 h plus tard, les sacs à dos commencent à peser
et les vieilles douleurs de pied
ou de genoux se réveillent déjà.
Les trois semaines d'instruction ont laissé des traces.
- Allez, Katiuscha, donne le ton !
Le chant est censé donner du courage à la troupe.
- Allez, halte au chant ! C'est une grosse merde.
C'est quoi ce truc ?
Katiuscha est un chant russe,
un classique dans la Légion étrangère.
Chicos, lui, n'a pas le cœur à chanter.
Son visage ruisselle de sueur.
Il souffre visiblement.
Un état inquiétant, car à ce stade de la marche,
personne ne transpire comme lui.
C'est enfin la pause.
Chicos fait mine d'aller bien.
Il vient d'entendre quelque chose
d'intéressant dans les rangs.
- Marche ou crève, ça veut dire quoi ?
- Marche ou crève, oui.
- Ça veut dire quoi ?
- Les gens disent tout le temps, marche ou crève.
Mais un sergent a remarqué que Chicos va mal.
Hongrois lui aussi, il veut que son compatriote
aille jusqu'au bout de la marche.
Il lui donne quelques conseils.
- Si tu mets à un côté une bouteille d'eau,
tu mets pareille de l'autre côté, pour équilibrer le sac.
J'ai remarqué qu'il transpire beaucoup
par rapport aux autres.
Vous voyez toute cette partie-là.
Tourne-toi !
Moi, c'est juste la veste.
Mais lui, même le pantalon !
Tout est mouillé.
L'adjudant-chef Leroy décide de faire
marcher Chicos à ses côtés.
Il craint un coup de chaleur.
C'est une situation incompréhensible,
car Chicos est théoriquement un grand sportif.
Pourtant, son état se dégrade très rapidement.
- Allez, on se met sur la droite.
Allez, troisième groupe, faites une pose.
J'ai déjà vu quelques coups de chaleur,
lui, c'est vraiment bizarre.
Transpirer comme ça,
même à l'arrêt et même avant l'effort.
Je ne pense pas que ce soit normal.
- Dans les deux jambes, il a des crampes,
là et sur les côtés !
- Est-ce qu'il imagine ne pas finir la marche képi blanc ?
- S'il le faut, il s'arrête tous les dix mètres,
mais il va jusqu'au bout.
Il marchera avec moi, à côté de moi.
Il reste une dizaine de kilomètres avant le bivouac.
Stanchou est désigné pour porter le sac de Chicos.
- C'est très lourd ?
- Non, ce n'est pas lourd.
- Pourquoi fais-tu ça ?
- La camaraderie toujours.
Stanchou n'a pas le choix.
Tous pour un.
Tout le monde se relaiera pour porter le sac de Chicos.
Seulement voilà, même allégée, ses jambes ne le portent plus.
L'adjudant-chef craint un accident, il décide de l'arrêter.
- Vous mettez tout le monde à l'ombre.
Pose 10 minutes !
- Voilà, c'est bon, il va embarquer là.
C'est bon, parce que là, on ne va pas tuer un mec non plus
pour son plaisir.
Le but est d'arriver vivant, c'est pas d'arriver mort.
- Il est un peu dégoûté !
- Bah, oui, mais c'est la vie.
Il ne sera pas le premier.
- Il ne reste que 3 km...
- Oui, mais ça va être de pire en pire.
- Je voudrais y arriver.
Chicos veut y croire.
Mais pour lui, la marche képi blanc
est bel et bien terminée.
Il devra passer des analyses médicales
et réussir la prochaine marche,
sinon il sera éliminé de la Légion étrangère.
Au bivouac, l'abandon de Chicos est dans toutes les têtes.
Les plus fragiles doutent.
Demain, il reste 30 km à parcourir.
Tous le savent, ce sera de plus en plus dur.
6 h du matin et déjà dix kilomètres
dans les jambes depuis le bivouac.
Aujourd'hui, pas de sourires,
encore moins de chants.
La plupart des soldats ont les pieds en sang.
Mais pas question d'abandonner si près du but.
- Combien de kilomètres reste-t-il à parcourir ?
Ils n'en ont pas la moindre idée.
Seuls les instructeurs le savent et se taisent.
Quelques heures plus tard,
un premier panneau,
puis un deuxième redonnent du moral à la troupe.
C'est apparemment la fin du calvaire.
- C'est bon, allez serrer vers l'avant, tous.
- Ça sent le képi blanc !
- Ça sent la fin !
- Allez, vers l'avant !
Il ne reste que quelques centaines de mètres,
mais il y a une dernière surprise.
- Souriez ! On croirait des morts.
Allez, c'est parti, hop la !
L'arrivée se fera au pas de course.
Une torture, histoire de montrer aux soldats
qu'ils ont des ressources insoupçonnées.
Le képi blanc, ça se mérite.
Tout est une question de mental, paraît-il.
- Allez, avancez, ... !
Groupez ...
- Lever la tête.
-  Les sergents, vous récupérez les groupes
contrôle PAM et on embarque et on dégage.
- On range vos quartiers.
Remise en condition,
puis préparation de la remise Képi blanc.
- On se pose même pas 2 minutes ?
- Non, non, ils vont boire un coup dans le camion. C'est bon.
- Allez, c'est parti !
- Quand on n'en peut plus, on en peut encore !
C'est dans la tête.
- Même après trois semaines d'instruction ?
- Même après trois semaines d'instruction.
Et puis bon, il y a la petite fierté.
Ils savent que ça se termine
et ils ne sont pas morts non plus.
Et là, ça les prépare tout doucement,
à courir avec un sac à dos.
Ça, c'est l'objectif suivant.
Un peu plus tard, dans un village près de Castelnaudary,
c'est enfin l'heure
de sortir le képi blanc du sac en plastique.
Dans quelques minutes,
les soldats seront enfin des légionnaires,
mais Chicos n'est pas de la fête.
Prends-le !
Dans les rangs, un soldat se sent mal.
À bout de force, apparemment.
- Donne-lui à boire.
Toi aussi ?
Il est tout blanc, lui, on l'emmène.
Ramène-lui un Orangina.
- Emmène-le, lui, il va mourir, on dirait un squelette.
- Il a tout donné et il a plus rien.
Et qu'il ne touche pas à la bière, par contre.
Dans le village,
la cérémonie est un événement à ne pas manquer.
- Désormais, vous mettrez tout votre honneur,
à mériter chaque jour ce képi,
en respectant les valeurs qu'il représente.
Coiffez vos képis blancs.
- Nous promettons de servir avec honneur et fidélité.
- Félicitations !
- T'es de quelle nationalité ?
- Italie.
- Italie, bon ! Tu vas rester chez nous ?
Tu vas continuer ?
- Oui, mon commandant !
- Bon courage ! Je te félicite.
- Bravo ! Bienvenue à la Légion étrangère.
- Merci.
Chicos est déçu, mais il a encore une chance,
dans deux semaines.
- Ils sont légionnaires
et moi engagé volontaire !
- Et ça fait une différence ?
- Oui, c'est sûr !
Il devra terminer la prochaine marche ou quitter la Légion.
- Vous voulez faire une photo ?
- J'ai un peu d'émotion, ça se passe une fois dans la vie.
Mon cœur bat comme ça !
- Qu'est-ce que tu attends maintenant ?
- J'attends d'aller dans mon régiment.
au 2e REP, toujours.
C'est tout !
- Qu'est-ce que tu vas faire avec cette photo ?
- Je vais en faire un méga poster !
- Tu vas l'envoyer en Italie ?
- À ma maman !
- Qu'est-ce qu'elle va penser quand elle va le voir ?
- Que je suis fou.
Politi, Stanchou, Chicos d viendront-ils des parachutistes ?
Il reste encore trois mois d'instruction.
Rien n'est gagné.
Les parachutistes du deuxième REP,
les voilà à l'entraînement.
Au sol, le sergent-chef Chebel observe.
Il est inquiet pour les hommes qui viennent de sauter.
- Je suis dans le caca, là !
Quatre ont ouvert leur parachute de secours.
Pour lui, la marche képi blanc est un vieux souvenir.
Le chef Chebel est ce qu'on appelle un REP man,
depuis 11 ans.
- Ils se font mal à l'atterrissage ?
- Là, heureusement, la voile n'a pas déventé là.
Mais elle commence un petit peu à se dégonfler.
Si à 20 m du sol, elle se dégonfle,
le parachutiste qui chute, il percute la planète,
il va se faire mal.
Chebel est chef de section.
Il a une vingtaine d'hommes sous ses ordres.
Parmi eux, le légionnaire Sorkin.
Un an et demi de service, il vient de Sibérie.
C'est un homme peu bavard.
Sorkin avoue seulement
avoir eu une vie agitée avant la Légion.
- On est tous pareils ici !
Il n'y a pas de mongols, il n'y a pas d'idiots.
Il n'y a pas de très intelligents.
On est tous pareils !
Lui aussi est sous les ordres de Chebel.
Le caporal Michoulski est polonais,
il a trois ans de service
et compte bien faire toute sa carrière ici.
Cette vie de Redmans,
Chebel, Michoulski et Sorkin l'ont choisi.
Ils l'ont choisi pour le prestige, peut-être.
Pour le  frisson, sûrement,
et pour d'autres raisons
qu'ils gardent pour eux, comme tous ici.
En cas de conflit,
les Redmans seront largués au-dessus d'une zone de combat.
Ils sautent donc avec tout leur barda,
casques lourds et armes d'assaut comprises.
Dernières recommandations.
- Rupture de l'estomac,
tors !
Jusqu'au vent d'attaque.
Je fais ventral.
Faire ventrale : Ouvrir son parachute de secours.
Cela se produit souvent.
- Tu n'as pas fait beaucoup de sauts ces derniers temps ?
- L'année dernière 29.
Cette année 3.
- Du coup, tu as un petit peu peur ?
- Un peu.
Sorkin est nerveux,
car il manque d'entraînement cette année.
Comme tout le monde ici,
il redoute de se blesser à l'atterrissage.
Pour ce saut, c'est le chef Chebel, le largueur.
- En avant et au paquet. Allez la 4 !
Chebel va superviser le parachutage de ses hommes.
Altitude, 300  seulement.
Douze secondes pour larguer 25 parachutistes.
Chebel est armé d'un couteau.
Si un homme reste accroché à la carlingue,
il devra couper la sangle
pour éviter que l'avion ne s'écrase.
Revenu au sol, le légionnaire Sorkin a retrouvé le sourire.
Tout s'est bien passé.
- Il n'y a rien de dur...
- Tout est facile ?
- Oui, tout !
Tout est possible au 2e REP !
Michoulski, lui, ne cache pas son enthousiasme.
Sauter, il adore ça !
- T'es venu ici pour ça ?.
- Ben, oui !
J'étais parachutiste, chez moi, en Pologne.
Et puis comme je ne pouvais pas rester là-bas,
à cause du nombre de places dans l'armée de parachutistes.
Et je me suis dit : tant pis !
Tant pis pour eux !
Tant mieux pour la France.
Ces parachutes ronds ne sont pas dirigeables.
- On ne sait pas, si on sera largué sur le grillage.
ou de l'autre côté de la route.
Ça peut arriver.
On sait ce qu'il faut faire.
Comment il faut protéger la tête, le visage.
Comment il faut protéger nos parties intime.
Se protéger et gérer les incidents de saut, cela s'apprend.
Rien ne vaut l'expérience.
Ces hommes viennent d'arriver au 2e REP.
Ils ont peu d'expérience, juste quatre sauts.
Un légionnaire a déclenché son parachute de secours,
en blanc, mais il ne s'est pas gonflé
et menace d'entraîner la voile principale.
- Oh punaise, le ventral !
L'homme panique, complètement empêtré dans la voile,
il ne voit plus rien.
- Groupez !
Il parvient à se dégager
et heurte le sol tant bien que mal.
- Oh p*****, il ' y en a un sur le toit !
Un autre légionnaire a eu moins de chance,
il vient de percuter le toit d'un hangar.
- Ça arrive souvent comme ça ?
- Très rarement !
- Qu'ils se posent comme ça.
- Dans le quartier, il se peut.
Quand il y a énormément de vent.
L'homme a traversé le toit.
Il est à cheval sur une poutre en métal
qui a retenu sa chute.
Un médecin militaire est sur place.
- Qu'est-ce qui peut arriver dans un cas comme ça ?
Parce qu'il n'y a aucun moyen de faire sans rouler boulé...
-Qu'il tombe directement par la pente,
ou alors qui tombe à l'intérieur
avec tout l'entrelacement métallique.
Donc là, le risque,
c'est qu'il était en appui sur la barrière.
Donc, qu'il se fasse vraiment mal au dos.
Puis après, on se retrouve avec un parachutiste
pendu au milieu du hangar.
Blessé, potentiellement blessé.
- Il s'en sort bien ?
- Là, il s'en sort bien. Il peut repartir.
Comme ça, il n'a pas le temps de se poser de questions,
surtout que c'est un jeune à l'instruction.
C'est son quatrième saut.
Il ne faut pas que qu'il tergiverse et donc il faut y aller.
- Tu as vu que tu allais sur le bâtiment
et tu tractionnes quand même sur le bâtiment.
Oui, parce que...
- Il y avait un autre bâtiment derrière ?
Seulement, tu es un peu disjoncté !
- C'est des choses qui arrivent !
Mais c'est notre travail !
La peur, c'est normal.
Ça fait réfléchir.
Il ne s'en rend pas compte,
mais ce jeune légionnaire a eu beaucoup de chance.
Une semaine après notre passage,
un parachutiste s'est tué à l'entraînement.
Un accident rarissime.
Chez les paras, on appelle cela la part des anges.
- Je veux faire encore 2 sauts cet après-midi.
La mort en saut ou au combat fait partie du métier.
Les légionnaires n'en parlent pas.
Le chef Chebel a choisi ce risque en connaissance de cause.
Confort de la vie civile, vie de couple, situation stable.
Il sait ce que c'est. Et pourtant.
- Ma vie ne me convenait pas.
J'en avais ras le bol, ça me plaisait pas.
La seule solution pour moi de recommencer à zéro,
en laissant tout derrière, sans accroches,
c'était la Légion.
J'ai plaqué maison, femme, tout !
Mobilier, j'ai tout laissé.
J'ai pris un sac, 2, 3 affaires de rechange
et je suis parti.
- 11 ans de légion, c'est 11 ans sacerdoce ?
- Non, il y a des petites rencontres.
Mais c'est vrai que là, maintenant,
j'aimerais bien fonder une famille,
parce qu'on vieillit, on vieillit
et j'aimerais avoir un fils.
- On ne dit pas que la Légion, c'est une famille ?
- C'est une famille.
Mais bon, le jour où on s'en va,
c'est fin la famille légion.
J'espère avant que je parte à la retraite un jour,
faire un saut,
un saut opérationnel !
- C'est un peu sauter en enfer ?
- C'est notre métier, on s'entraîne pour ça.
Moi, je forme mes légionnaires pour ça.
L'entraînement, c'est l'entraînement.
Mais là, il n'y a pas la sanction du feu.
J'aimerais voir avec la sanction du feu ce que ça donne,
mais je suis confiant.
Les deux guerres mondiales, Diên Biên Phu, l'Algérie.
Les légionnaires ont souvent connu la sanction du feu.
Dans son histoire, la France a souvent préféré envoyer
les étrangers au combat.
De toutes les armées, la Légion étrangère a payé
le plus lourd tribut à la guerre.
Le dernier assaut du REP,
c'était à Kolwezi, au Zaïre, en 1978.
Une opération audacieuse
pour sauver des milliers d'Européens du massacre.
Depuis, le REP n'a plus sauté,
mais il est intervenu partout, de l'Irak à la Côte d'Ivoire,
comme ici.
- Bouge pas petit.
Ces images, en trois ans.
- Encore, tirent un coup !
Les rebelles ont torturé cet enfant
et l'ont relâché pour le tuer à distance.
- C'est quoi ça ? C'est des coups de quoi ?
Sans l'intervention des légionnaires, il serait mort.
- C'était quand, ce matin ?
Le maintien de la paix aujourd'hui,
c'est l'essentiel de leur travail.
Les légionnaires du 2e REP peuvent partir n'importe où
et à n'importe quel moment.
Ils ne quittent jamais la Corse sans autorisation expresse.
Le capitaine Lancelot Dampierre est officier.
Il commande la quatrième compagnie,
celle des destructeurs sniper.
Sorkin, Michoulski et Chebel en font partie.
Travailler dans la Légion pour un officier,
c'est un choix de carrière prestigieux.
Dampierre l'a fait sans hésiter,
tout comme son père et ses trois frères.
- Comme on est sur une île,
on a non seulement tout ce qu'il faut,
mais en plus, nos personnels sont toujours là
parce qu'on ne quitte pas l'île comme ça.
Il faut prendre l'avion ou il faut prendre le bateau.
Si on était sur le continent, le week-end,
il n'y aurait plus personne,
parce que les gens partiraient à droite,
à gauche en week-end.
Ici, le fait d'être sur l'île,
tout le monde reste dans la garnison,
c'est-à-dire à Calvi.
- Et comment on se fait accepter par ces bons hommes ?
- Comment on se fait accepter ?
En faisant son travail, en travaillant, ..., en travaillant.
C'est tout.
- Dans ces chambres, les légionnaires,
il reste cinq ans. C'est ça ?
- Oui, oui.
- Ils sont combien par chambre ?
- Ils sont 5 à 6,
- Mets-toi au repos.
Le capitaine Dampierre accepte
de nous expliquer un point délicat,
le changement d'identité.
En réalité, le légionnaire Sorkin ne s'appelle pas Sorkin.
- Donc là, il est sous identité déclarée.
Donc le nom n'est pas son véritable nom.
La date de naissance non plus et parfois même le pays.
Cette identité déclarée est valable pour tout le monde.
Tout légionnaire qui arrive
est mis sous une autre identité.
Il va être mis sous entité, pourquoi ?
Parce que les gens viennent ici à la Légion étrangère.
Pour connaître une certaine rupture,
connaître un nouveau milieu.
Donc tout le monde va connaître cette même rupture.
Sans différence entre celui qui aurait eu des problèmes
dans le passé ou celui qui n'en a eu aucun.
Maintenant, point particulier,
c'est que certains légionnaires
peuvent demander à être sous anonymat,
mais c'est une mesure qui est très contraignante pour eux.
C'est ce qu'a connu Vitellius.
Puisqu'ils n'ont pas le droit
d'avoir de contacts avec l'extérieur.
En échange, on ne parlera pas de l'extérieur.
S'il y a un problème, il n'existe pas.
Par exemple, on les passera pas la caméra, etc.
L'anonymat du caporal Vitellius vient juste d'être levé.
Une délivrance !
- Pendant trois ans, quatre ans.
Tu n'as pas passé un coup de téléphone, pas écrit ?
- Non, rien du tout.
- Si la gendarmerie, par exemple, se présente à l'entrée
et dit : Voilà, nous cherchons Monsieur X. Vous le donnez ?
- Moi personnellement, non !
Non, parce que je n'ai pas cette prérogative
de pouvoir dire à un gendarme oui, j'ai bien Monsieur X.
Tout simplement.
Donc moi, c'est hors de question !
Maintenant, ça, c'est une question qui est du ressort
du chef de corps, du colonel commandant de régiment
et de la voie sécurité Légion étrangère.
Maintenant, c'est à eux de voir ça.
- Vous vous connaissez leur véritable identité ?
- Non, non, et je ne veux pas le savoir.
Sorkin a fait une demande pour retrouver sa véritable identité.
Après deux ans de service, il y a le droit.
Il pourra bientôt quitter la France en permission
ou simplement prendre un abonnement téléphonique.
Réponse dans quelques mois.
- Oui.
Le caporal Michoulski, lui, a déjà retrouvé sa véritable identité.
Il veut rentrer dans son pays pour les prochaines vacances.
Mais comme tout légionnaire, il doit demander l'autorisation à son capitaine.
- Caporal Michoulski, 3 ans de service, 2 mois de grade,
4e compagnie 3e section, fonction chef d'équipe.
À vos ordres mon capitaine !
- Mets-toi au repos !
- Je me mets au repos mon capitaine.
- Tu viens pourquoi ?
- Je voudrais demander permission étrangère, mon capitaine.
- Pour aller où ?
- En Pologne.
Sa demande sera examinée par les services de sécurité
de la Légion étrangère.
- Parfois, les réponses sont négatives.
- Par exemple ?
- Ça peut arriver par exemple avec la Pologne.
- C'est quoi le problème avec la Pologne
- ? Ils n'admettent pas que les Polonais
travaillent dans des armées étrangères, tout simplement.
- Donc, qu'est-ce qu'il risque ?
- Il risque entre 3 mois et 4 ans de prison à peu près.
En Pologne, Michoulski a fait son service militaire.
Théoriquement, ils ne risquent rien.
18 h, les gradés peuvent quitter le quartier.
Tous les autres restent,
sauf ceux qui ont une autorisation spéciale.
C'est le cas du caporal Vitellius.
Il veut fêter sa levée d'anonymat.
Tenue de sortie obligatoire et attention au repassage.
- Les plis sur la poitrine
et les distances entre les plis, c'est 3,5 cm.
Là, c'est 5,3 cm.
Le caporal Michoulski, lui, ne sort pas.
Il s'est cassé un doigt en sautant.
Et de toute façon, il est de service.
- Je m'occupe de la section après 17h30
car il n'y a plus de cadres.
Donc, je ne peux pas sortir.
Si je sors, qui va s'occuper de la section ?
Chacun doit montrer son autorisation de sortie.
- C'est bon, bonne soirée !
Hors saison touristique, les rues de Calvi sont plutôt calmes,
mais les quelques touristes présents trouvent
les légionnaires plutôt exotiques.
- C'est vraiment bizarre,
tout le monde nous regarde, comme des chacals.
Eh regarde, les légionnaires !
C'est un truc de fou.
- Tu aimerais sortir en civil là ce soir ?
Tu aimerais être habillé comme moi ?
- Je voudrais bien, mais je ne peux pas.
- Mais tu aimerais ?
- Ouais.
Au quai d'honneur de Calvi,
les yachts à plusieurs millions d'euros pièce
affiche un luxe tapageur.
Bien loin du confort sommaire des chambres.
- Ça vous fait rêver des bateaux, comme ça ?
- À mon avis, ça coûte très cher.
Un bateau comme ça.
- 1 mètre, 1 million.
- 1 mètre, 1 million ?
- À peu près...
- Il y a des légionnaires qui sont devenus milliardaires.
- Ex-légionnaires, ça existe bien sûr.
Ce n'est pas mon but de devenir milliardaires comme ça.
Je préfère plus l'aventure !
Il y a une bonne ambiance dans notre chambre.
L'ambiance des militaires, des vrais hommes !
Et dans quelques jours,
les vrais hommes de la quatrième compagnie
s'envolent pour l'Afrique.
- Vous les mettez à l'intérieur !
Direction Djibouti.
Ils y resteront quatre mois.
Dans le paquetage, aucune affaire civile.
L'Afrique fait rêver,
Mais ils savent qu'ils n'y vont pas pour rigoler.
- C'est pas des vacances.
C'est un stage commando.
- Ça va être dur ?
- Oui, ça va être dur.
- C'est mieux de rester ici, alors ?
- Non, c'est mieux de travailler là-bas, qu'ici.
- Ça, c'est des linguettes bébé ?
- Oui, ce sont des lingettes.
- Pour les fesses des bébés et vous vous l'utilise pour ?
- Pour enlever le camouflage rapidement.
- C'est vrai que c'est un peu marrant, mais bon.
L'expérience dit que c'est pas mal.
Une compagnie qui part en projection,
c'est 160 hommes avec tout leur équipement et les armes.
Des tonnes de matériel.
Alors chaque sac est pesé, 20 kilos par légionnaire, pas un de plus.
Le sergent-chef Malone a 23 ans de service.
C'est sa dernière mission à l'étranger.
Il supervise le chargement des containers.
- Vous en avez fait combien de départ comme ça,
dans votre carrière ?
- 16ᵉ, peut-être 15ᵉ !
- C'est le dernier ?
- Le dernier.
- Après, c'est fini ?
- Après, c'est terminé, je laisse ça aux jeunes qui arrivent.
Dernière mise au point à la veille du départ,
le chef Malone n'est pas content.
C'est au sujet des bagages de cabine.
- Y en a un, sa musette faisait 6 kg.
Dedans, il y avait au moins 150 stylos,
son GPS, son godemiché, etc.
Gore-tex, votre bouquin de cul pour l'avion.
Et c'est tout.
- Donc, Warnung !
Vous avez intérêt de vous comporter comme il faut.
Je vous considère comme des hommes.
Comportez-vous comme des hommes.
C'est bien clair.
Dans les chambres, on fait place nette.
En l'absence de leurs habitants habituels,
ces locaux peuvent accueillir des militaires de passage.
Galons oblige, le caporal Michoulski
est exempté des tâches ménagères.
Il a donc tout le temps pour ranger ses affaires personnelles.
- C'est le drapeau de la Pologne !
- Et le drapeau français où est-il ?
- Dans la tête !
Le légionnaire Sorkin, lui,
veut envoyer quelques cadeaux en Russie avant de partir.
Il y a une peluche pour sa fiancée.
- C'est l'insigne de notre compagnie :
Destructeurs, Snipers !
- C'est un nounours 2e REP ?
- Oui, c'est ça.
Quelques photos de manœuvres
pour impressionner les copains.
Dans l'avion, grand exercice compagnie, balaise !
Une médaille pour sa mère.
- La médaille de la Défense Nationale, c'est pour ma mère.
- Pour votre maman ?
- Oui maman.
- Elle va être fière de ça, votre maman ?
- Ouais.
Aéroport militaire de Solenzara, le lendemain.
Un avion a été spécialement affrété.
- Vous allez entrer à la porte, ici.
L'adjudant va venir et va contrôler.
Il y a de l'excitation dans l'air.
Le chef Malone connaît ses hommes,
il craint des débordements.
- Il y a 3 hôtesses très jolies, bien roulées dans l'avion.
Le premier qui leur met la main au cul,
je m'en occupe personnellement.
Et s'il est trop grand pour moi,
c'est l'adjudant Tulub qui s'en occupera.
- Qu'est-ce qui se passe dans leur tête ?
- Ah bah, ils sont heureux de partir.
Eux, leur seul but, c'est de partir en projection.
-Ils vont en baver normalement.
- C'est rustique, c'est parfois dur.
Ils ne demandent pas à être choyés.
Ils demandent à être pris en mains,
à vivre pleinement l'aventure militaire.
Dans 5 h, la compagnie des Destructeurs Snipers
se posera en Afrique.
La République de Djibouti sur la mer Rouge
est une ancienne colonie française.
Aujourd'hui, plus de 2500 militaires français
et autant d'Américains y sont stationnés en permanence.
D'ici, ils peuvent intervenir partout en Afrique
et dans le Moyen-Orient.
Fer de lance de la présence française dans la
région, la 13ᵉ DBLE.
Ce matin, la section du chef Chebel
prend la garde du régiment pour 24 h.
- T'as la tête tordue !
Le caporal Michoulski est le clairon.
Sorkin et les autres vont être présentés
à celui qu'on appelle le caïd,
c'est-à-dire au chef de corps.
- Présentez armes !
2,10 m et cinq galons.
Le colonel Bilodell en impose.
Les légionnaires ont rarement l'occasion de le rencontrer.
- Légionnaire Sorkin, maintenant 6 mois de service.
- Fonction tireur ennemi.
- À vos ordres, mon commandant.
Monter la garde, cela fait partie du boulot de soldat.
Mais ces hommes sont venus chercher autre chose en Afrique.
Ils sont là pour un stage commando, le CECAP.
L'un des plus durs de l'armée française.
Chaleur extrême, humidité.
Toutes les conditions ont réuni pour de l'aguerrissement.
Nous les retrouvons dix jours après le début de leur stage.
Visiblement, ils sont acclimatés, mais déjà amaigris.
- Reçu.  Ouvrez le feu, détruisez !
Le chef Chebel s'est fixé un but.
Emmener tous ces hommes jusqu'au bout du stage,
leur faire décrocher la médaille du CECAP.
S'ils terminent, ils ne gagneront qu'une médaille.
Mais dans la Légion,
il y a bien ceux qui ont fait le CECAP.
- Feu, détruisez !
Et les autres.
- Ok, fait place à l'invasion.
6 h du matin, la section du chef Chebel
installe la piste nautique.
C'est une sorte de parcours du combattant flottant
censé rappeler les conditions de combat dans l'eau.
Au cours du stage, chaque légionnaire doit terminer
au moins une fois chaque épreuve.
Il y a toujours deux chances.
Cette piste nautique, ils la connaissent.
Ils l'ont déjà parcourue quelques jours plus tôt,
mais à l'entraînement, sans chronomètre ni sac à dos.
Comme ça, ça paraît facile,
presque un jeu.
Mais aujourd'hui, ce sera beaucoup plus difficile,
surtout pour les mauvais nageurs.
Dans leur dos, une musette et un fusil d'assaut.
- Ils ont combien dans la musette, en poids ?
- En poids, ils ont environ 5 kg.
Ils ont deux bouteilles d'un litre et demi, plus l'arme.
Avec l'arme, cela fait donc dix kilos de lest.
Le légionnaire Dudek n'est pas à l'aise dans l'eau.
- Je suis mauvais nageur, ça, c'est sûr.
Il sait qu'il a peu de chances de finir,
alors il compte beaucoup sur l'aide des autres.
Le parcours se fait par groupe de six.
- 1, 2, 3 !
- Aller vite, ça va bien.
Seulement voilà, le premier obstacle est celui
qui demande le plus d'organisation.
Le groupe doit passer par-dessus cette planche
à 1,50 m au-dessus de l'eau.
Impossible tout seul.
Évidemment, interdiction formelle de s'accrocher
à quoi que ce soit.
- Il faut se calmer dans l'eau.
Il ne faut pas faire des mouvements parasites,
qui vous entraine vers le font.
- Détendez-vous les gars.
Après 20 minutes, certains commencent à boire la tasse.
- Sortez !
- J'y arrive pas !
Dudeck panique, le chef Chebel préfère le faire sortir.
- Je vais couler maintenant !
- Tout seul, vous n'arrivez pas à monter un bonhomme.
Pour lui, c'est terminé.
- Il n'y va pas lui ?
- Non, il n'y va pas.
Neuf kilos, c'est trop !
- Monte !
- C'est quoi le problème ? C'est le souffle ?
- Non, je ne sais pas.
Pourtant, cet abandon soude le groupe.
Il trouve enfin le truc
ou la force pour franchir l'obstacle.
- Ok, les pieds !
- Vous en avez perdu un chef là ?
Ouais, c'était un mauvais nageur.
- Vous en doutiez ?
- Je ne savais pas trop,
parce que sans armes et sans musette, ça allait.
Mais là, c'est vrai que ça alourdit vachement la bestiole.
Dans la section, c'est l'hécatombe,
les abandons se succèdent.
5 en tout sur 20 hommes.
- P*****, ça glisse !
- Allez, vas-y, ...
Aujourd'hui, la mer est calme.
Les obstacles suivants sont à peu près stables
et beaucoup moins technique que le premier.
Reste que celui-ci, appelé la girafe,
est particulièrement glissant.
- Mets-toi debout, tiens le canon et saute !
- Continues, continues !
- Pousses sur les jambes.
- Allez, mets-toi debout !
Voilà, encore un peu.
- Allez, saute, saute !
Fin de parcours, après 50 minutes d'effort,
à bout de force et de souffle,
il termine par une apnée de huit mètres.
Et là aussi, interdiction de tricher.
- Allez tout le monde la main sur le poteau !
Dans deux jours, Dudeck, le mauvais nageur
et tous ceux qui ont abandonné
termineront la piste nautique.
Question de fierté, sans doute.
- Vous vous portez, on ne s'appuie pas sur les autres.
Bon, allez, tout le monde, la main sur la piste.
- Entre groupe, c'est important de comparer les temps.
Comme vous faites sur les circuits ?
- Il n'y a pas forcément une rivalité entre les groupes.
Non, on est tous de la même section.
Tous de la même section, il n'empêche,
sur certains obstacles,
un ou deux hommes ont oublié la cohésion.
À l'inverse, d'autres ont tout donné pour le groupe.
Cela n'a pas échappé au chef Chebel.
Ce stage est l'occasion d'observer les hommes,
d'avoir une idée de ce qu'il donnerait au combat.
- Détermination !!!
C'est l'heure du cours de corps à corps.
Un incontournable au CECAP.
Les légionnaires apprennent à se défendre
et à tuer à mains nues ou à l'arme blanche.
- Vous rentrez et en même temps
vous arrachez la trachée artère.
S'il faut, pique !
J'entre directement avec le tibia, jambe droite.
1, 2... Là, normalement, il va relâcher un peu l'étreinte.
C'est un peu normal. D'accord,
Je ramène les mains. J'écarte.
- Ça protège bien ça ?
- Comme ci comme ça !
Quand tu as un petit coup, oui,
mais quand c'est un gros coup, non.
- Ça fait mal ?
- Un peu.
- C'est encore utile, le corps à corps ?
- Et quand il n'y a plus d'arme, il faut bien utiliser
les  armes naturelles ou les poings ou les pieds,
ou en faisant les couteaux ou les sangles.
Si le fusil ne marche plus, comment on fait ?
Après, il faut atteindre la gorge,
et je fais lâcher l'arme.
- Le plus jeune dans votre groupe,
vous avez combien de différences ?
- On a 18 ans.
J'ai des jeunes qui ont 18, 19
je vais avoir 37. Le calcul est vite fait.
- Vous faites exactement la même chose qu'eux ?
- Pareil, mais moi, j'ai l'expérience en plus.
- Qu'est-ce qui vous motive ?
- La reconnaissance, plaisir de commander,
de voir le regard des gens que je commande,
voir leur sourire, voir quand on est dans la merde.
Quand on se tire sur la bourre, on est tous épuisés.
Il y a des sourires, il y a des échanges de regards,
il y a des choses qui se passent,
que je ne trouverai pas ailleurs.
- Vous comptez faire ça combien de temps encore ?
- Aucune idée. Advienne que pourra.
À 37 ans, le chef Chebel a de l'expérience. C'est vrai.
Mais dans un stage commando comme le CECAP,
les plus jeunes sont nettement à leur avantage.
Ils sont un peu inconscients.
Ils ont la souplesse, la résistance et la force.
Et surtout, ils récupèrent très rapidement entre les épreuves.
- On est des légionnaires.
On est tous un peu sado-maso.
Tous les militaires sont un peu sado-maso,
un peu de force, un peu de puissance,
un peu de fatigue et la transpiration.
C'est ça un militaire.
Et être militaire, c'est aussi ne pas compter ses heures.
Il est très tard,
les légionnaires se lèvent dans quelques heures,
mais dans un pays aussi chaud,
se coucher sans se laver est impensable,
même si l'eau est comptée.
- La salle de bain, ici.
- Les salles de bains, ça vous fait rêver ?
- Oui !
Chaque légionnaire n'a que deux tenues de combat.
Obligation d'en prendre soin.
Ici, la lessive se fait à l'eau de mer.
- La meilleure solution, c'est chaque soir,
même si on n'a pas beaucoup le temps.
C'est ma transpiration, c'est moi qui ai travaillé,
donc c'est moi qui dois laver !
On n'est pas des bourgeois.
- Attention pour les couleurs.
18ᵉ jour de stage.
Lever des couleurs djiboutiennes et françaises.
- Bonjour la section.
Ce matin, voie de l'inconscient numéro trois.
C'est-à-dire, voie de l'inconscient chrono !
- C'est parti ! On y va.
On se chauffe.
La voix de l'inconscient, c'est ça !
Une épreuve redoutée, car éliminatoire.
Ici, c'est chacun pour soi.
Pas question de compter sur les copains.
- Chut ! Dépêche-toi chacal, là-haut !
Dépêche-toi gros.
Certains obstacles sont à plus de 20 m au-dessus du vide.
- Monte !
Tu veux que je t'amène le café ?
- Tu y es presque là mon grand !
- Oh p***** !
- C'est rien !
- Ils sont fatigués là, en fin de parcours, comme ça ?
- Énormément. Ils arrivent au bout, il n'y a
plus de bras, il y a plus de jus.
Le caporal Vitellius est un ancien sportif de haut niveau.
Jusqu'à présent, il a beaucoup donné
pour les autres et n'est pas très bien classé.
- Allez jusqu'au bout.
Cette épreuve est enfin l'occasion de montrer ce qu'il vaut.
Il veut battre le record huit minutes.
- 8,37.
- C'est un bon temps ça ?
- Excellent. Excellent.
- Il y a 37 secondes en trop pour avoir un 20 sur 20,
mais c'est un bon temps.
- C'est pas une surprise
pour vous qu'il ait fait un bon temps ?
- Non, parce qu'il se démarque un peu partout,
sur toutes les pistes.
Le chef Chebel s'élance à son tour.
Son objectif n'est pas d'établir un record,
mais de faire mieux que les jeunes pour l'exemple.
Le chef est à la peine.
Pour l'instant, il est derrière les premiers.
- Sur la fin, j'ai merdé.
Mais bon, douze minutes, c'est pas mal.
Ils ont fait quoi les premiers ?
- Quatre minutes dans la vue !
- C'est normal, à 20 ans, le cœur y tape.
Sur le câble d'arrivée, le légionnaire Sorkin.
- Il est physique. Il est tout sec, il est tout maigre.
Il devrait voler sur les obstacles.
Il donne tout ce qu'il peut,
mais il a deux minutes de retard.
Une petite victoire pour Chebel.
- C'est un vieux réflexe et quand tu es à fond,
j'ai accroché...
Mais ce qu'il veut surtout, c'est que tout le monde finisse.
Et là, ça s'annonce mal.
Au pied de la gouttière, un légionnaire est en difficulté.
Le chef l'a compris, il n'ira pas plus loin.
- Allez !
- Il faut finir le stage, ça coûte.
La France nous paye...
Ce n'est pas pour venir ici et faire ce qu'on veut
et toucher l'argent.
Non, non, ça ne se passe pas comme ça.
- Mets tes pieds à plat sur la paroi au maximum.
Au même endroit, un deuxième donne des signes de faiblesse.
Mais le chef veut y croire.
- Ils écoutent pas !
- Tu montes pas, tu changes de béret !
- Sers tes pieds,
mais qu'est-ce que t'écartes les pieds comme ça, là !
Les pieds contre le tube !
Bordel !
- Descends !
- Il va se péter le bras.
- Maintenant, c'est foutu, mon vieux,
je peux rien faire pour toi.
Fait chier !
Deuxième échec, le chef est furieux.
Il sait que ce légionnaire n'a pas tout donné.
- Partout où, je l'ai vu, il ne se donne pas.
Il est toujours dernier, il est toujours à la ramasse.
C'est toujours les autres qui ramassent,
pour qu'il puisse être ici.
Là, il est individuel,
il y a personne qui peut l'aider et il est échec.
Pour moi, il n'a rien à faire la légion étrangère
puisque quel que soit le poste, la Légion étrangère,
on est tous amenés à aller au combat.
Ce n'est pas un militaire,
il n'a rien à faire dans l'armée, en général.
- Ceux qui ont fait mieux que moi ici, là !
Ceux qu'ont fait moins bien que moi, ici.
Tout ça, vous êtes derrière le chef, c'est pas normal.
Allez, embarquez !
Casse-croûte et après on y va.
- Encore 18 h et c'est finex ( fin d'exercice)
Trois semaines, ça passe vite.
On a ramassé,
mais c'est comme ça.
- Tu connaissais pas l'Afrique, toi ?
- Non, c'est la première fois.
- C'est différent de la Sibérie ?
- Bien sûr que c'est différent.
Il y a des cailloux partout, partout...
- Chez toi, c'est comment ?
- C'est plein de forêts, de montagnes avec de la neige.
C'est balaise !
- Tu penses à chez toi ?
- Oui, j'y pense.
Je vais demander la permission étrangère,
si ça passe bien, je vais aller chez moi...
peut-être.
Le lendemain au-dessus du golfe de Tadjourah.
Chaque fois qu'il le peut,
le colonel Billaudel fait le déplacement
pour remettre leurs médailles
à ceux qui ont terminé le stage.
Évidemment, le capitaine Dampierre est du voyage.
- Dans un régiment de Légion, le chef de corps,
c'est celui qu'on appelle le caïd.
C'est celui qui, effectivement, se doit d'être présent.
Lorsqu'il y a des rendez-vous importants
pour les légionnaires
et je crois qu'une fin de stage au CECAP,
c'est un rendez-vous important pour un légionnaire
et on les voit en place, effectivement, ils m'attendent.
- Bon, ça va, c'est bien rangé.
Vue d'hélicoptère, c'est bien rangé.
- On n'a pas vu d'en haut.
- Je vous le dis moi !
Chebel, il finit quand même major de sa section.
- Et de tout le stage, il est deuxième.
- Quand on voit un sergent-chef qui termine en tête de sa section,
un stage comme le CECAP, c'est rassurant.
Et puis, c'est un bel exemple pour les jeunes légionnaires.
- Quatrième caporal chef Bac.
- Il regarde tous les légionnaires,
donc aussi moi j'arrive derrière.
Mais je ne pensais pas être premier quand même.
Je me disais dans les 5 premiers, oui, mais premier, non !
- Certains ont pu se révéler, se dépasser,
apprendre à connaître d'autres limites.
Et pour nous, c'est un bon stage,
parce que qu'on cerne mieux certains personnages
qui, plus tard, pourront faire d'autres activités,
avoir d'autres fonctions et progresser.
Progresser, mais dans un seul but
faire un jour le grand saut et
réussir l'épreuve du feu.
De retour en France, à Aubagne,
nous retrouvons les légionnaires que nous avions quittés
lors de la cérémonie du képi blanc, il y a trois mois.
L'instruction est terminée.
Leurs chemins se séparent.
Chicos, qui n'avait pas fini la marche,
porte-lui aussi un képi blanc.
Il l'a obtenu deux semaines après les autres.
- Je suis le grand-père,
et toi le père !
- Tout le temps, il dit : je n'ai pas fait mon lit,
Aidez-moi avec mon lit !
Comment tu as rangé ton armoire ?
Ah, comme ça, c'est bien.
- Maintenant, c'est un bon légionnaire.
Ces analyses médicales n'ont rien révélé d'anormal.
Nous remarquons une dizaine d'absents.
Certains sont blessés ou ont abandonné.
C'est le cas de Politi, l'Italien trahi par son genou.
- Il est parti dans le civil, très costaud,
mais il avait des soucis avec la marche et le footing.
- Il n'était pas fait pour la Légion ?
- Non !
Il est fait pour être garde du corps.
- Permission d'entrer ?
Un par un, les légionnaires vont apprendre leur affectation.
Pour Stanchou, le deuxième REP, c'est oublié.
La vie insulaire l'inquiète,
le parachutisme ne le fait plus rêver.
Stanchou veut devenir sapeur dans le génie,
sur le continent.
- Bon, t'es toujours content d'être à la Légion ?
Fier d'être légionnaire ?
- Je peux aller où la Légion a besoin de moi.
- Exactement, tu fais une réponse de bon légionnaire.
Stanchou, je t'affecte au 2e régiment étranger de génie.
- À vos ordres, capitaine.
C'est bientôt au tour de Chicos.
Alors, il révise.
Ce qu'il va dire devant le capitaine
est écrit sur un petit papier.
Méthode efficace finalement,
car ses progrès en français sont spectaculaires.
- Tu vas aller au REP ?
- Non, le REP, c'est terminé.
- REP terminé ?
- Terminé, parce que j'ai eu des problèmes avec la marche.
et je pense changer de régiment.
Je veux partir au 1er REC Cavalerie à Orange.
et peut-être après dans 5 ans,
j'irai au 2e REP à Calvi.
- Ah, tu veux encore aller au REP ?
- Je veux aller au 2e REP parachutisme !
C'est l'élite, c'est nickel !
En réalité, Chicos n'ira jamais au REP.
Il aimerait piloter des blindés.
Il mesure 1,65 m et pense que c'est un atout,
pour rentrer dans un char.
- Bon, qu'est-ce que tu veux faire à la Légion ?
Dans quel régiment voudrais-tu aller?
- Je pensais au 1er REC cavalerie.
- Pourquoi le premier REC ?
- Parce qu'il y a beaucoup de missions
comme l'Afghanistan et le Kosovo,
et je suis petit.
Et la cavalerie, c'est bien pour les gens petits !
- Ok, Chicos, eh bien écoute, je t'affecte au 1er REC.
Aller, tu peux disposer !
- Je veux disposer, à vos ordres, mon capitaine.
Avant de rejoindre leurs régiments,
Chicos, Stanchou et les autres
doivent accomplir un dernier rituel à Aubagne.
- Vous portez tous le même képi.
Quel que soit le régiment dans lequel vous allez servir,
vous faites partie d'un seul bloc qu'est la Légion étrangère.
Pour marquer cette entrée symbolique
dans la famille de légionnaires.
On va maintenant descendre dans la crypte
pour se recueillir une petite minute
en la mémoire de tous nos anciens.
Dans cette crypte,
vous retrouvez les trois symboles de votre engagement.
Tout d'abord, le drapeau français,
c'est les trois couleurs de la France,
le pays que vous êtes engagé à servir.
Vous trouvez la main du capitaine Danjou
qui symbolise ce serment que vous avez fait
et qu'ont fait tous les légionnaires.
Enfin, gravés en lettres d'or sur les murs de la crypte,
vous avez les noms de tous les officiers
qui sont morts à la tête de légionnaires
dans le cadre des missions opérationnelles.
Pour toujours, gardez en souvenir, cette notion du risque.
- Saluez !
Pour ce groupe, la vie de légionnaire
commence réellement maintenant.
Nous sommes à Nice, sur la Promenade des Anglais.
Le caporal Michoulski est en permission.
Dans 1 h, il s'envole pour Varsovie.
À Djibout, il a gagné plus de 15 000€,
mais il a juste gardé de quoi se payer un billet d'avion.
- Merci.
- Tout l'argent de Djibouti, il n'y a plus rien ?
- On s'en fout, on s'éclate !
Pas question pour autant de ramener les souvenirs
du 2e REP à ses proches.
Le caporal Michoulski préfère rester discret.
- Ta fiancée, quand elle parle de toi,
elle dit que tu travailles en France et c'est tout ?
- Ils ne savent pas que je suis légionnaire.
Je travaille en France, je travaille dans une campagne,
mais je ne dis pas que je suis légionnaire.
C'est mon secret.
C'est de chez moi.
La fiancée se contentera d'un peu de vin corse.
- J'habite à Calvi.
- Bonne soirée.
- Merci.
- Bon après-midi.
- Merci à vous-même.
- Et ça, c'est le cadeau ?
- Pour elle. Mais le cadeau, c'est moi.
Pour moi, le meilleur cadeau, c'est elle.
Le caporal Michoulski ne restera
que deux semaines dans son pays.
À son retour, il devra rendre
son passeport à ses supérieurs.
Le première classe Sorkin, lui,
vient de retrouver sa vraie identité, Alexeï Zamiatine.
Mais il n'a pas encore de passeport.
Alors, il a invité sa mère et son frère à Paris.
C'est lui qui a payé le voyage.
Et justement, les voilà.
- Il a changé, il a grandi un peu.
Il est bronzé, ça fait deux ans qu'il a quitté la maison.
- Qu'est-ce que tu veux voir à Paris ?
- Je veux voir ce qu'il y a de mieux à Paris !
- Le Louvre, la Tour Eiffel, tout...
Tout ce qui est beau.
- La tour Eiffel aussi ?
- Oui.
C'est la première fois que sa mère
visite une ville aussi grande.
Alexis veut l'impressionner.
Il faut dire que Paris,
c'est un peu sa nouvelle capitale.
Mais pour lui, le quartier le plus intéressant à visiter,
c'est la défense.
De l'acier, du verre et des tours qui n'en finissent pas.
Dépaysement garanti pour la babouchka de Sibérie.
Et ça marche. Elle adore.
- Il n'y a pas de mot, c'est beau.
- Ça vous plaît l'architecture moderne ?
- Oui, oui....
Je vais raconter ça à toutes mes copines
et à mon travail.
Je vais leur montrer les photos.
- Elle va les montrer à tout le monde.
- J'ai dit à mes copines qu'il allait partir en Afrique
et qu'ils allaient tuer mon fils
avec leurs arcs et leurs flèches.
- Vous êtes fier maintenant de lui ?
- Ouais.
- Je suis contente, mais je m'inquiète quand même !
La maman d'Alexeï n'a pas fini de trembler.
En attendant, elle compte bien profiter
de ces sept jours dans la Ville Lumière,
avec son légionnaire de fils.